قمعت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الفلسطينيين والطواقم الصحفيه في حي وادي
الجوز الملاصق لسور البلده القديمه في
القدس قبل موعد صلاه الجمعه وكانت قد منعت
المصلين من الوصول الى المسجد الاقصى
واطلقت عليهم قنابل الغاز المسيل للدموع
واعتدت عليهم
بالضرب لمزيد من التفاصيل معنا من القدس
مراسله الجزيره جيفارا البديري جيفارا كنت
قد اشرت سابقا الى ثلاثه اطواق امنيه ونوع
من
الحصار على منطقه المسجد الاقصى لمنع
المصلين من الوصول اليه كيف تطور
[موسيقى]
الموقف نستطيع القول الان حسن انه كان
هناك اربع اطواق وليس فقط ثلاثه
لانه كان هناك ايضا حواجز طياره وفق دائره
الاوقاف الاسلاميه في داخل المسجد الاقصى
المبارك لتف تيش هواتف من تمكن من الدخول
الى داخل المسجد سنبدا هنا بدايه حسن من
هذا المشهد قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اي
تقوم الان بتخفيف الاجراءات بعد ان انتهت
صلاه الجمعه بعد ان غادر من تمكن من
المصلين من دخول المسجد الاقصى المبارك
ولكن هذا التخفيف جاء بعد قيام قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بقمع كل من حاول
الوصول الى خارج اسوار البلده القديمه
بمعنى كنا نتواجد هنا في حي وادي الجوز
عند المقبره ايضا حاول بضع فلسطينيين
الصلاه عند باب الاسباط عند باب العمود من
يتمك من حاول حتى الاقتراب من الاسوار تم
قمعهم حتى قبل بدء صلاه الجمعه وبالتالي
الاطواق نتحدث طوق عسكري حول القدس طوق
عسكري حول اسوار البلده القديمه
وداخل البلده القديمه بمعنى حول المسجد
الاقصى المبارك وايضا في داخل الباحات
للمسجد اليوم كان العدد نوعا ما اعلى من
الاسابيع الا 11 الماضيه لسببين وفق هي
مصدر مطلع في دائره الاوقاف الاسلاميه لان
هناك كان دعوات للفلسطينيين من القدس ومن
داخل الخط الاخضر بمن يتمكنون بالطبع فقط
هم من الوصول الى قدس ل الصلاه وبالتالي
كان هناك محاوله من داخل الخط الاخضر
بوصول حافلات الى داخل المسجد الاقصى
المبارك ولكن الاهم من ذلك انه واضح على
الارض على الاقل وفق ما راه كثير من
الصحفيين انه لا يوجد اعداد كبيره من قوات
الشرطه والجيش الاحتلال هنا في الازقه
لانه لا يوجد اصلا كل معظم يعني كل الجيش
الاحتلال منتشر في كل المواقع و
الشبهات المفتوحه وبالتالي كان هناك
محاوله اليوم للتخفيف ولكن عمليات القمع
بقيت على حاله الطواقم الصحفيه ايضا تعرضت
سوالي المياه العادمه لقنابل الغاز نتحدث
عن مياه عادمه كيميائيه وبالتالي القمع
بقي كما هو وايضا هناك حالات اعتقال
جيفارا البديري شكرا جزيلا لك حدثتنا من
القدس